Christian Bale is like the master of
weight gain and loss I mean skinny huge
skinny huge I don't know how that guy
does it man
[Music]
American hustle is directed by David
O'Russell and stars Christian Bale
Bradley Cooper Amy Adams Jennifer
Lawrence and Jeremy Renner this movie is
based off a true story and in Hollywood
you know it's just it's they have some
ideas that happened one time and they're
gonna like talk about it and I like the
fact that a sentence that appears on the
screen the beginning of the movie
basically pokes fun at the fact that
Hollywood is like that and I thought
that was pretty cool what this movie is
essentially about in a nutshell is con
men being forced to con other con men by
an FBI agent who's trying to con the con
man so they can be captured on tape
being con men that's a in a nutshell so
most movies about Christian Bale and Amy
Adams are both these people who run this
business that basically takes money from
people who are in a horrible spot when
Bradley Cooper who plays an FBI agent
discovers this he then uses them by
blackmailing them essentially to force
them to do other cons on people so that
they can be caught in exchange for them
not going to jail Jennifer Lawrence is
the other woman the Christian Bale is
worth that she's a little nutty Jeremy
Renner plays this really good-hearted
mayor who just wants to help the people
of New Jersey but maybe every once a
while takes a bribe and all these
characters mesh together in a film that
is extremely hilarious that is on all
the time this movie never turns off it
is always on that's my best way to
describe this movie and it is one of the
best films I have seen all year and the
soundtrack the soundtrack in this film
is so cool everything is so jazzy and
disco even funky and it just feels so
right for this error that they're trying
to portray Christian Bale's pulled off
two great performances now at the end of
the year I thought it was great and out
of the furnace here he is the best I've
seen him in a while I mean he's
unrecognizable he's got this comb-over
here he just owns as this guy and he
captures that great line where an actor
if you start to cross this line you
become flashy and look at me I'm a cool
actor and I'm rich and famous and I
more talented than you he is so great at
not crossing that line because so many
actors do that you just feel like okay I
get it you're freaking act they're good
for you every actor in this movie was
phenomenally invested in their parts amy
adams does the best work i think i've
ever seen from her actually bradley
cooper in this movie is like the perfect
mix of hilarity uncontrolled rage and
ferocity his character is so difficult
to lock down as a person because each
scene he has like this whole new thing
going on with him like where he was kind
of okay in the previous scene the next
scene he's just really frigging mad he
doesn't so well and it's so hilarious
also hilarious in this movie is jennifer
lawrence who seems to be a completely
unstoppable actress i mean what is going
on with you you woman you just keep
being awesome in movies except for house
at the end of the street hmm
yeah her character in this movie is so
repulsively idiotic but she finds the
perfect note to make that enjoyable to
watch jeremy renner is also good movie
all the acting is really good in the
movie but the script ah the script every
line in this script
feels so well thought out and
meticulously crafted nothing feels
superfluous everything feels like it
should be there and every scene counts I
continued to wait for that one scene
that didn't fit or wasn't important or
was just like a time waster it never
came the directing style from David or
Russell is big and flashy but it doesn't
feel arrogant I think that my best way
to describe how much I loved this movie
was it all seemed to be riding this line
where if you just cross it in the wrong
way it's gonna start to suck everyone's
performances were larger-than-life and
huge but as I said about David or
Russell's directing style not arrogant I
was transfixed to the screen for every
minute of this movie the way it opens is
the kind of opening where you have to
understand other things before you can
really understand what's going on and
you're listening to every little bit of
dialogue that escapes these characters
mouths because it's so clever and so
funny and so well-written this is one of
the funniest movies I've seen all year
it has some of the best performances
I've seen all year it's a movie that
from start to finish I was never once
bored with I don't spoil anything about
the movie I told you the basic plot and
that's all you're
to me this is an A+ movie so guys if you
see American hustle I'm very curious to
know what you thought of it and as
always if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck nice
[Music]